robots are taking over people I keep
talking about this and I firmly believe
it's happening in the next 20 years or
so and now Google has bought one of the
military's biggest suppliers of robots
that's right they've bought Boston
Dynamics these guys make robots for them
and all kind of mechanized
machines for war and we've got some
video this first one is of wild cat
sorry it doesn't look that scary but the
buzzing I guess could be annoying right
that looks oh that looks scary alright
actually being chased by bees it's
powered by bees I think this next one
this is pac-man
all right so these are we're laughing
about it but these are robots that we
are gonna send to war one day we talk
about robots on this show all the time
how long until the robots take over and
Skynet and we have to destroy them and
we have to bring John Connor to save us
all of all it is Boston Dynamics so
they'll be going to wha yes they're
being used by the army yes to go to war
really though I'm just a firm believer
that these robots are gonna turn against
us you know we've talked about the
singularity on this show and that just
all this technology we're gonna build
things that are gonna be more powerful
than we are and they're gonna be able to
learn without us and then they won't
need us anymore
am i a complete paranoid loon we're
already seeing that happen with some
jobs I mean we're seeing the development
of driverless cars for instance and even
if you go to the grocery store an even
smaller level right there are self
checkout booths so you don't even have
to deal with the cashier so what is that
going to mean for the job market I think
that it could be problematic it already
is problematic for some they're losing
their jobs as the results of robots
taking over their jobs but what I also
wanted to make a point about is how
Google is always a step ahead of
everything right they are just
dominating in terms of search engines
and online products and technology but
pretty soon they will be paid
contractors for war and it will feed
into the military industrial complex
we'll have another company that makes a
ton of money and and incentivizes going
to war so I see that is problematic as
well so I know we're focusing a little
too much on the downsides there could be
positives because it would be cool to
send a robot to to war as opposed to
risking human lives but at the same time
I mean there are huge downside right but
you could also argue that if we were to
send a robot into war that that robot
would have less remorse let's say than a
regular soldier and could do far more
dangerous things so like those drones
that just blew up the the wedding and we
said robots into war instead of human
beings we'd still be saying them to kill
human beings it's still not a good idea
on the whole look thirty years ago the
the whole issue was we need to create
all these devices for the home for
4050 years ago now washing machines and
vacuum cleaners that would reduce and
and and assembly line machinery that
would reduce the the need for human work
so that we could all have more leisure
time and take greater pleasure in life
and support the arts and the pure
sciences and all the things that could
make life really worthwhile and joyous
for Humanity well it might have worked
out nicely if we didn't live in a
capitalist system that demands that
people constantly keep producing
something new and consuming something
new at the same time in order to
maintain an ongoing steady stream of
income based on the untenable idea that
we have unlimited natural resources I
think if we can focus the idea of
robotics and and mechanized labor toward
the betterment of mankind that'd be
great but we're not the replacement and
it's the use for war that has been
driving our economy since 1975 and I
think it's time we really started to
re-evaluate what the purpose is of the
development and the technological
advances that we make as long as there's
a profit motive and as long as we live
in this capitalistic society nothing is
gonna change this this robotic movement
will continue and the question is what
will we do as Americans to adapt to that
new world what will we do in our job
market because people are gonna lose
their jobs people are being replaced so
how do we adapt to that I mean we have
the trouble of outsourcing right we're
losing jobs in that way now we have
robots taking over and you know you'll
have people make the argument that hey
you know what if robots can do this job
we don't need people right sorry isn't
that the argument that people against
raising the minimum wage always say well
if you raise the minimum wage then we'll
just make everything mechanized and then
everyone will be out of a job which
first of all let me say that is if if
we're gonna deal with the sort of the
fantasy scenario that robots would take
over if that's going to happen it's
going to be likely because we treated
them as
lave labor and when you create a new
form of slave labor you're likely to
eventually create resentments I mean I
think that that ultimately what we need
to deal with is what is the purpose of
our creation of Technology I have a
theory I believe that the the planet is
as a whole evolving and we are part of
that we are essentially an organ we move
sugar from one place to another and we
transfer we turn it into energy and we
move oil from one place to another and
we turn it into energy we create the
networks that are allowing the planet to
begin to think and right now it is an
adolescent and all the planet is
thinking about as a whole it's not
really all that conscious it's not
self-aware it's just thinking about
boobies and lower mortgage rates and
that's really it right now but things
that really matter though only only to
an adolescent ultimate ultimately i I'm
not saying I don't like him I'm saying
my brain does not constantly think about
them and mention them to anybody who
will listen there I've mentioned to 1/3
of the people who will listen so um my I
believe there is a Gaia principle at
work and ultimately if robots replace us
that might be a natural evolutionary
process I buy that this is just luck
technology we use technology we have
brains and we learn about science to
just get to the next level of things and
things aren't inherently bad
so last thought on this though is there
something possibly inherently bad about
the fact that we now have basically two
companies Google and Apple that are
buying up everything else so you used to
have like you know a scientist in his
shop or something in his workshop
building something and it was his life's
work but now anytime Google or Apple see
anything interesting they buy up because
100 million bucks or 300 million bucks
or we've even seen a billion dollars for
Instagram is nothing and is there some
risk in that that we just have these two
giant companies competing to buy up
everything else it kind of reminds me of
media conglomerates except with media
you know if you have a few major
companies controlling the message then
you're not really going to get the
old story but with with Google and Apple
buying everything yeah definitely I do
see that as problematic especially when
we lack a regulatory system in the US
you know we have this this age of
deregulation and I worry what that will
mean for the average worker and you know
the average small business owner right
how are you gonna compete with a huge
company like Google and Apple right it's
one thing to compete with them when they
have more money and everything else but
when they have robots - and you still
have to pay a human could be a problem a
risk and realization and the
consolidation of wealth how could that
be a problem we are slowly reverting
America is turning into Dickensian
England and it's because capitalism grew
out of feudalism and when you keep
pulling the the constraints off of it it
just becomes feudalism again only now
it's not troubled by all that difficult
noblesse oblige that required that the
the wealthy take care of the poor